of the most damaging things we can do
for our bodies is sitting and sitting
for large periods of time unfortunately
most of us do spend huge amounts of time
sitting in fact for many of us sitting
is how we spend the majority of our time
and this has a number of serious and
negative effects on our bodies sitting
for long periods causes tight hip
flexors weak glutes a weak core poorer
breathing tight hamstrings rounded
shoulders tight pecs stiff neck a whole
host of other issues fortunately by
using corrective exercises there are
lots of ways we can address these
problems and using one exercise in
particular we can tackle a whole host of
these issues in a single go that
movement of course being the crab so the
crab is an exercise that exists across
many different training disciplines many
modalities you have the crab pose from
yoga you have crab from animal flow
which involves slightly less hip
extension of course it's also part of
just movement training more generally
you have similarities in capoeira you
have the crab toe touches often used as
a warm-up by gymnasts and the crab in
its more general form is often used in
functional training and corrective
exercise to help address a lot of
movement red flags I love it when you
see this a different movement pattern
reoccurring in different disciplines
just because it has so much Clear
benefit for the human body but we often
don't see it in the gym it's not
something you see many gym Bros using
and I do think that's something we
should change because it particularly
has benefits for anybody who's a little
bit front heavy perhaps or a little bit
stiff and I recommend you try it because
as soon as you try the crab pose and
especially the crab reach for me you
feel it and it feels excellent it feels
great it's like the kind of stretch it
makes you go ah and to me that's a sign
that you probably really need it
okay so first of all you're gonna sit
down on your big old butt the grass is
slightly dewy and wet here but we're
gonna make do then what you're gonna do
is put your hands by your side put your
feet on the floor so your knees are up
and then you're simply going to push
your waist up towards the floor so that
your pelvis is trying to touch the sky
fortunately the positioning is quite
straightforward and simple you want to
make sure that your wrists are directly
under your arms which directly under
your shoulders that's going to place the
minimum amount of strain on your wrists
at the same time you want to make sure
that your legs your shins are
perpendicular to the ground so you're
creating a right angle same thing for
your arms and then you'll want your
torso to be a straight line parallel
with the ground and ideally what we're
going for here is a straight line
directly from the shoulders all the way
down to the knee now I'd like to take a
moment to talk about today's sponsor
nordvpn so nordvpn is a VPN that means a
virtual private Network basically it
allows you to surf the web in a way that
makes it harder for people to see your
activity or to identify your IP address
that's because it lets you reroute your
traffic via a server located elsewhere
where so that if someone were to spy on
you all they'd see was that you
connected to that server all your
subsequent activity would be obfuscated
this of course makes bows in the web
much safer also means you can spoof your
address so if you want to look like
you're browsing from another location
for example so that you can access
region locked content on sites like
Netflix this is a great way to do that
you can watch more programs wherever you
are in the world whilst at the same time
getting Peace of Mind knowing that your
data is safe nordvpn also comes with a
host of other features including double
VPN which offers double encryption if
you go to nordvpn.com forward slash the
Pioneer then you can get a big discount
on a two-year plan plus an additional
month thanks again to nordvpn for
sponsoring this video and now on with
the show so of course the key feature of
the crab pose is to engage the glutes
contract the glutes and make sure that
you're really rotating the femurs and
pushing the pelvis up towards the sky
you want to do this without arching your
lower back and the reason this is so
incredibly beneficial is because this is
exactly the opposite of how we sit when
we're sitting in the office often what
we're doing is we've got our hips flexed
we're bent over hunched over and as a
result we get tight hip flexors we
deactivate our glutes we struggle to
engage them meaning in some cases we can
get a permanent anterior pelvic tilt so
that our pelvis is tilting forwards
giving us that Donald Duck Butt at the
same timing will often bend over in that
way and pick things up from the ground
by bending the lower spine instead of by
engaging the glutes often we can't
Engage The glute properly when running
When jumping so this is a great antidote
to that and this nice isometric hold is
going to give you the opportunity to
really ingrain those movement patterns
as you focus on engaging the glutes and
Contracting there whilst at the same
time maintaining that neutral lower back
in terms of your neck position ideally
you want to try and keep that neutral as
well so straight line you can tilt It
Forward slightly we don't really want to
be tilting it all the way forwards
because that's going to be creating more
neck flexion bending yourself more
forwards which is exactly what we're
trying to counteract because again if
you're at the phone a lot or at the
computer like you're going to be bending
your neck Force like that it's not the
end of the world it's not going to
instantly cause you damage like some
people would have you believe but if
we're trying to reinforce positive
movement patterns that ain't one so it
makes sense to try and keep the neck
nice and neutral
but if you're struggling to get into
that fully opened up hip position what
you can do is to drop it slightly now
it's going to look more like that crap
position from animal flow they also put
their fingers back we'll talk more about
that in a moment
but by just relaxing the hips slightly
more you make it into an easier position
that's easier to hold but at the same
time you're still engaging those glutes
you're still Contracting those glutes
and that's still going to give you the
opportunity to strengthen them so that
eventually you can get into that nice
opened out position think about this
it's very similar to a hip thrust the
difference being that instead of resting
your upper body or shoulders on a bench
you're instead resting them on your
shoulders it's not only going to involve
the upper body making it into a great
bang for your buck exercise but it also
slightly increases the range of motion
takes you close to that end range
strength where you're pushing against
your body's own resistance don't push
hard and cause an injury but just gently
try and find those limits and get into a
position where you can comfortably
challenge them that's what you can also
do is to just practice that as a range
of motion as a hip thrust you can just
relax the hips and then push them up to
the sky that's going to look something
like this
that then also brings us to a number of
great other variations on this movement
of course you've got the crab walk
oh hey babe
nice sweater
you can do this with the hips completely
extended or you can do it in that more
relaxed position our animal Flow by
moving through this position you're
teaching yourself to stabilize the core
and activate the glutes while also
moving the body which is of course
what's important
so it's just a great form of strength
endurance training a Great conditioner a
great warm-up and it looks like this
[Music]
there's a lot of dogs at this park
do you know how to do the crab reach
your mommy's over there
great thoracic rotation
another great one is the crab toe touch
and we're going to be doing here is
getting into that crab position then
reaching one hand forwards to touch the
opposite foot this is another great
stability and core challenge it's
anti-rotational because you're bracing
the core to stop yourself twisting
either to the left or to the right
you've only got two points of contact
with the ground meaning you need to
create a lot of stability to do this
correctly and at the same time there's a
slight Mobility challenge there too as
you're trying to touch your foot and
touch your hand really would work well
in a high intensity functional training
circuit now the other big feature of
this position of course is opening up
the chest and in that position you're
going to feel the nice stretch on the
chest perfect again for if you spend a
lot of time hunched over like this
typing with your pecs flexed and in a
shortened position if you want to take
this a little bit further what you can
do is to point your fingers out behind
you which is actually how the animal
flow position looks as well we can do
this in order to externally rotate the
shoulders opening them up even more and
opening up the chest even more but of
course it also puts a bit more pressure
on the shoulders and on the wrists so
you want to ease into that position
gradually by turning your hands more and
more out behind you if that's a feature
that you're looking to take advantage of
well and you want to keep those arms
nicely locked out and as you drive and
rotate them into the ground you're also
developing that straight arm strength
this protects your elbow from injury
during movements like the deadlift it's
also perfect for developing the kind of
strength you need for moves like the
planche l-sit ETC then there's another
one I've been playing around a lot with
lately that's the crab reach what you
can do here is just simply reach over
with one arm and then we're going to do
is push the arm over the opposite
shoulder and as you do follow it with
your gaze so that your head is tracking
the movement stretching out the obliques
the quadratus lumborum and building that
thoracic rotation that so many of us are
missing I talk a lot on this channel
about the importance of rotation for
everything from throwing to running to
wrestling to throwing a punch to moving
heavy objects we always rotate the core
and yet so little of what many of us do
in the gym involves rotation place your
weight onto one side you might need to
slightly rotate the hands to get
comfortable going to lower your hips and
then push through the hips push through
with the arm over the opposite shoulder
and as you do follow that hand with your
eyes so that you're tracking it and
creating that really nice thoracic
rotation you should feel the stretch
down the whole side of your body
even in the lats
and because it perfectly opens up the
shoulders like this this is a fantastic
movement for throwing for martial arts
especially something like Jiu Jitsu
where you're also getting that nice
pelvic thrust so if you want to start
incorporating the crab into your routine
then you can use these isometric holds
as part of a Mobility routine you can
use it as part of a cool down I
recommend that for a warm-up you instead
use something like the hip thrust that
we looked at or maybe the slightly more
relaxed version The Crab walks because
this way you're not maintaining a static
stretch it's more of a moving Dynamic
stretch and this is just a really nice
way to ease into that movement to really
activate the glutes in a really safe way
if you want to start using those
isometric holes then I recommend that
you start with a Target that's
achievable for you 20 30 seconds do this
three times and then perform it maybe
three times a week you can then build up
to a minute or longer and start to
really see that difference and just go
easy with it remember it's a marathon
and not a Sprint
so that's the crab the crab pose the
crab reached the crab toe touch what do
you think is an exercise that you
already use is it when you're going to
start incorporating into your training
and if not what exercises do you use to
combat the detrimental effects of
sitting for long periods let me know if
there are any other exercises you'd like
me to highlight in the comments down
below if you want a training program
that looks at restoring functional
movement and takes you beyond that to
Super functional performance
incorporating everything from strength
to Mobility to cardio explosiveness then
check out my ebook and training program
that comes with over two hours of
instructional video called super
functional training 2.0 the protein
performance system I'll put a link to
that in description down below thank you
so much for watching guys
and bye for now